well a movie that most lost vegans know
by heart celebrating its 25th
anniversary casino
gives us all a look back into our city's
gritty and glamorous history and
tonight some of the film's key players
look back on their experience for those
who didn't know part of our channeling
property the hughes house
acted as a set for some pretty iconic
scenes sasha loftus reports
it's been 25 years since casino
first hit the silver screen and its
reverence still
holds true here it was a time of
sort of you know glamour and glitz and
and promise and opportunity and also a
lot of heartache and
violence you know but that is sort of
the big
the las vegas that people really
identify with
to celebrate the classics anniversary
screenwriter nick palegi
and former las vegas mayor and attorney
oscar goodman
led a special event on thursday sharing
the parts
they played in this well-known
masterpiece
goodman didn't just live through the era
he also portrayed himself
in some pretty iconic scenes i've been a
lawyer here for 35 years and
the mayor here for 12 years and i go
into an airport and they say oh there's
a guy from casino
the creators also reminisced on the ways
news stations like ours
helped writers bring local history to
life
it's taken literally from you know the
news footage that was taken by channel 8
at the time
so you know that was very important to
creating an authenticity
as we all look back on these pivotal
moments
these men will always remember sasha
loftis
8 news now